dennoch gibt es jetzt vor ort an der
bären schütz klar
weitere dramatische entwicklungen denn
es wurde ein drittes todesopfer gefunden
mein kollege jörg völkerling ist jetzt
vor ort jörg was kannst du uns fand vor
ort aus österreich berichten
das bild hat sich heute morgen wieder
vollkommen gewandelt nachdem ich jetzt
wo zwei tage hier ankam da war die
größte rettungsaktion schon gelaufen und
die beiden todesopfer waren geborgen
heute morgen als ich jetzt wieder nach
mixnitz gekommen bin war auf einmal ein
polizeihubschrauber wieder auf der wiese
die beamten machten mich darauf
aufmerksam dass sie eben ein drittes
opfer aus der klamm geflogen hatten
hätten
und erst vor circa einer stunde ist hier
der leichenwagen auf dieser wiese ein
wenige hundert meter talabwärts
vorgefahren hat die leiche des 30
jährigen slowaken von dem man bisher gar
nicht wusste dass er noch vermisst war
der vergangene nacht also gefunden wurde
hat man die geborgen und weggefahren
makabre weise wenige meter daneben steht
immer noch sein verlassenes auto mit dem
er mittwoch ihren diese beeren schütz
klar gekommen ist um einen schönen tag
an diesem kühlen ort zu verbringen
wie geht es jetzt dort weiter die bären
schütz klamm ist ja beliebt bei
wanderern jetzt dass dieses unglück
passiert kann man dem überhaupt
vorbeugend derzeit ist ja auch alles
gesperrt
ja die bürgermeisterin der gemeinde
planegg hat schon angekündigt hat ein
betretungsverbot erlassen hierfür die
brandschutzklappen sie sagt es ist was
nicht wahrscheinlich dass die klammen
dieses jahr überhaupt noch einmal
aufmacht es ist ja nicht nur die gefahr
mit den steinen die immer wieder
runterkommen können kieselsteine große
stein ist immer mal wieder abgegangen
aber hat nie so dramatische folgen wie
jetzt man sieht auch die schwierigkeiten
bei der bergung das wird sicherlich die
bergrettung noch im nachhinein zu
besprechen haben
man sieht wie schwierig es sein kann
opfer zu finden im fall des 30 jährigen
slowaken wurde der offenbar stand über
dem wasserfall ist 30 meter in die tiefe
gerissen worden und wurde dann wohl von
dem wasserdruck in vier meter tiefe
festgehalten man vermutet dass er
möglicherweise auch schon einem felsen
noch runter gedrückt wurde und man hat
ihn dann erst nach einer vermisstmeldung
von freunden am gestrigen abend hat man
dann noch mal in diesem trüben wasser
mit stange
gesucht und wie mit der leiter der
bergrettung in der steiermark
geschrieben hat hat man dann durch
tasten durch rasten im trüben sozusagen
ist man auf etwas weiches gestoßen und
konnte diese leiche dann bergen